foreign
the Toronto Blue Jays are on a winning
streak off it they're in turmoil we
definitely don't want anyone feeling any
hurt
um you know we're we're focused on the
environment we care about this community
we care about our fans and I I deeply
regret if people do feel that way
certainly was not Our intention pitcher
Anthony bass who had posted his support
for a homophobic video on social media
was supposed to cast the ceremonial
first pitch Friday for the start of the
team's celebration of Pride weekend
until the Jays dumped him hours before
the game it does send a little bit of a
mixed message in my opinion he's going
to be center stage and now he's going to
be booted off stage that's kind of like
what what I hear it was only a day ago
Blue Jays GM Ross Atkins called bass
more enlightened more aware of the hurt
he'd caused here we are after fan outcry
a 180 and bass has no future in Toronto
there's a myriad of variables
performance is is usually the driving
one and performance was a large aspect
of this decision
distraction was a small part of it and
you know something that we had to factor
in it's been a turbulent 10 days since
bass promoted and shared a video
instructing Christians to boycott Bud
Light and target for supporting lgbtq
plus initiatives this is evil this is
demonic we won't stand for it bass gave
a Kurt apology met with pride leaders to
discuss his beliefs and then try the
apology again Thursday only this time he
threw a little more spin on it claiming
he doesn't find it offensive I do not
that's why I posted it originally when I
looked back at it I could see how people
can view it that way
and that's why I I was apologetic
baseball writer RJ McDaniel says the
Jays had no choice other than perhaps
cutting bass sooner I think that they
felt that they needed to cut their
losses immediately without having the
distraction spy several even more out of
control but that's being on the field
for the Pride Celebration now a weekend
intended to be all about inclusivity in
sport is focused on a guy who won't be
there unless he buys a ticket microwave
Global News Toronto